la palma activa nuevamente sus alarmas
la erupción del volcán cumbre vieja se
intensificó esta madrugada a pesar de la
urgencia del tema un fenómeno de
esparcimiento ha cobrado importancia
turistas internacionales acuden a
observar el espectáculo natural haciendo
de la experiencia un momento único
lo que pasa aquí no lo ve todo el mundo
y para nosotros estar aquí una noche
como 12 horas fue una experiencia muy
sorprendente porque nunca lo habíamos
visto
para la tranquilidad de los visitantes
según el plan de emergencias volcánicas
de canarias pevolca las recientes
emisiones de lava corren sobre colas
previas por lo que no representan
peligro para otras superficies según
autoridades no hay indicios que señalen
una pronta finalización de la actividad
en el cráter así que el turismo
continuará
y escuchas hablar de los volcanes y te
imaginas la potencia pero cuando es por
ti mismo lo que está haciendo debe ser
muy difícil para la gente que vive aquí
deben estar muy asustados porque la
potencia es asombrosa pero los
residentes en la palma no ven con tanta
felicidad la experiencia en casi 50 días
de acción el cumbre vieja devastó un
promedio de 1000 hectáreas de terreno
destruyó a unas 2500 propiedades y su
estallido constante mantiene a
467 personas realojadas